[Music]
oh i don't mind this it's the chair
the chair is just the box
it tears you up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you want
i'm fine
i'm gonna need to ice my knees at the
end
what's your favorite thing about the
little set
is the eisenhower
and the little
they for some reason the tiny pencils
are stuck in here i can't take them out
and use them
with some kind of putty i don't know why
that was important
but um
[Music]
during the commercial break
sexual positions inhabited fetishes
really into people's sexual fetishes
they're much more candid
off camera oh that that makes sense
they're shockingly candy
they'll tell me all kinds of stuff
perfect
shaquille o'neal likes to dress as
charles lindbergh when he's doing it
[Music]
the funniest thing about this is that in
the commercial breaks the guests are so
big that their knees are killing
and we gotta lift them up off the couch
so they can stand
in between because they would not be
able to sit through an entire commercial
break it's too painful
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what are you gonna do with the little
set when it's all done
we don't waste anything so i think i'm
just going to
use this
as an apartment like a piano
[Applause]
hey conan o'brien here this is what i
look like just after a show sorry it's
not pretty i just wanted to say thanks
for watching and for using the sync app
we'll see you around